CHRIS: Hey guys.
Thanks for coming out.
Today we've got another
author talk here at Google.
Alexa Clay is a leading expert
on subculture and innovation
from unlikely places.
She's the co-author of
"The Misfit Economy",
a book that explores underground
and informal information.
She works to create
bridges and opportunities
for misfit subcultures
within the formal economy.
She's the founder
of Wisdom Hackers,
an incubator for
philosophical inquiry,
and the co-founder of the League
of Intrapreneurs, a movement
to create change from
within incumbent systems
in big organizations.
Alexa has written and
appeared in "Fast Company",
"Forbes", "Wired", "Dazed
and Confused", "Vice",
"Harvard Business Review",
the "New York Times", and MTV.
Please give me a hand
in welcoming Alexa Clay.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEXA CLAY: Awesome.
Thanks, Chris.
Thanks, Google for having me.
How are you guys doing?
Excellent.
So I want to share, really,
three passions with you today.
The first, misfits.
For the past three years, I've
been traveling around the world
and speaking to pirates
and hackers and gangsters,
and really trying to better
understand the different faces
of entrepreneurship.
I think when we often
think of the personality
of the entrepreneur, it's
sort of the geek funder
kind, the Mark Zuckerberg
hoodie wearing college dropout.
And I wanted to really
expand that definition
and look at people
that we don't think of
but are often entrepreneurs in
the informal and black market
economies.
So I'll share a little bit
about that from my new book,
"The Misfit Economy".
And then I want to
talk about alter egos.
I've been experimenting with
alter egos now for a few years,
and it's a passion
I have that I hope
you'll leave today also
wanting to experience some of.
But my appreciation
for alter egos
really started when I had to
increasingly commodify myself
for this talking
head type culture.
And through Facebook,
through Twitter,
through developing
this LinkedIn persona,
increasingly individuals
are becoming brands.
And to escape some
of that pressure,
I started developing
people who were not me
who I could begin to play with
to escape the Alexa Clay that
was becoming everywhere
on the internet.
So I'll talk a little bit about
some of those experiments.
And then lastly, I want
to share a new project
that I'm working on that looks
at this idea of basically
an incubator for
the next messiah,
and really explores how
our spiritual and prophetic
traditions are being
shaped by the digital age.
So let's get started.
My real love and appreciation
for misfits, to some extent,
started with this
desire to look at people
who didn't operate within
traditional command and control
capitalism.
So for me personally, I
grew up with two parents
who were anthropologists.
I loved Joan of Arc and Henry
Thoreau, two famous misfits,
when I was younger, and my
mother actually researched
alien abduction while
I was growing up.
So she traveled
the world and spoke
to people who believed they
were somehow abducted by aliens.
And I think in some way, this
gave me a real appreciation
for talking to people who
made me deeply uncomfortable,
as well as preserving
unknowns, not
trying to come out pro
or con on whether or not
I thought aliens existed, but
appreciating that conversation.
I remember when I
was eight years old,
feeling both sort of
terrified-- As you're beginning
to distinguish between fantasy
and reality as a child,
the existence of aliens or the
possible existence of aliens
was deeply unsettling
and destabilizing.
But then I also
remember in addition
to fear feeling this
sense, really, of loss
at not being chosen as an
ambassador of the human race.
Like, why wasn't I being
abducted, if these aliens were
really out there?
And so going from this
experience of abduction
and alien encounters,
I started going
into a very different terrain.
I had always had a more
esoteric upbringing,
and I went into the
corporate heart of darkness.
I went into Fortune 500 and
multinational companies,
and within those
environments I really wanted
to understand them with
an anthropological eye.
What are the rituals?
What does it mean to put on that
office suit and play that game?
And how are some of these
bureaucracies functioning?
And within those
environments, I discovered
what appeared to me like a
lost tribe of corporate rebels.
We called them
intrapreneurs, or people
that were actively trying
to hack these cultures
from within.
So someone, for example,
like Dave Berdish, who I met,
who was at Ford Motor Company.
And he essentially was a
third generation auto worker.
His grandfather had been
a prominent activist
who worked at Ford.
He'd been beaten
by Ford's henchmen.
So he had this sort of love-hate
relationship with Ford.
And Dave is someone that very
much tried to become and adopt
a radical activist type of
perspective within the company.
So he got the company to
think more about human rights.
Oh yay.
OK.
So I'm going to fast
forward a little bit, then.
So here.
Corporate rebels.
So Dave was someone
who got the company
to think a lot more about
human rights practices.
He was trying to get
the company to build out
mobility solutions, so to
think beyond just automobile
manufacturing.
How do we actually create social
and environmental business
models within this company?
How do we begin to hack the
DNA of this old dinosaur,
and get it to become a little
bit more future friendly?
So I met tons of
people like this.
We started essentially what was,
like, Alcoholics Anonymous type
of therapy groups for them.
So we brought all
these corporate rebels
that we could find,
from Morgan Stanley,
from Ford, from Unilever, from
all these different companies,
and brought them together
to have a space where they
could peer mentor each other.
And from that was created to
the League of Intrapreneurs,
which basically provided a
global guerrilla movement
for connecting intrapreneurs
from across these companies
to work together.
And from there, I
got really interested
in working with people that
weren't just camouflaging
within the system.
I think intrapreneurs
really have
to hide some of
their bigger agenda
to actually make it fit
with corporate priorities
and figure out how to
game corporate systems.
And so I wanted to
really work with people
that were more guerrilla agents
on the outside of our systems,
working with people in the black
market and informal economies.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-We're lawbreakers.
One law made, a hundred
laws made to break us.
[CHANTING]
[MUSIC CONTINUES]
ALEXA CLAY: Great.
So you can see there
in the video some
of the different archetypes that
we focused on within the book.
And really the start
of this all began
with seeing the ways in which a
lot of these illegal economies
actually predated innovations
within the mainstream economy.
So, for example, McDonald's.
Before McDonald's invented
the franchising structure,
you actually had the mafia
and groups like Hell's Angels
that were using
this structure that
predated ways in which
corporations were using it
today.
Or looking, for example,
within the porn industry.
I think, thinking beyond
Hulu or YouTube or Netflix,
it was that video streaming
technology was first used
really within the porn sector.
And then for me, the real
epiphany for a lot of this work
began when I started
meeting people that
used to run drug businesses.
So one of the first
conversations I had
was with a guy who
made over $8,000
a week running a
heroin business,
and he was an
amazing entrepreneur.
I came to see that
even though he
was on the wrong side of
the law in a lot of ways,
he was managing a
product, building a brand,
doing customer recruitment,
retaining employees.
He did all the things that any
traditional entrepreneur would
do, and yet he ended
up going to prison,
and in getting out of prison he
didn't have many opportunities
for employment.
And so he got connected with a
program called Defy Ventures,
and the purpose of Defy
Ventures is basically
to bridge these worlds of
formal entrepreneurship
and the traditional
venture capital community
with the world of
prisons and ex-cons
and people that do have
these amazing entrepreneurial
leadership skills
but need to plug
into formal entrepreneurship.
And so Defy Ventures
runs what is
a bit of an incubator or
accelerator for people
to pitch and grow their skills
within the formal economy.
And another conversation
that I had really
early on was with
someone called King Tone,
and he was the former
leader of the Latin
Kings, a Hispanic street gang.
And they had just undergone,
in the late '90s, one
of their deadliest
periods, where
the gang had done
this internal purging,
and they were really being
penetrated by the FBI
and at risk of
losing their license
to operate in a lot of ways.
And Tone was someone
who really was thinking
about how to do
change management
from within this gang culture.
He wanted to ask, what if we
take this gang and transition
it more into a social movement
like the Black Panthers?
And so he built alliances
with activist groups,
and really tried
to upscale the gang
to develop some of these skills
to become more of a civic actor
rather than just being dependent
on the criminal economy.
And he encountered a
lot of challenge there.
There were many people
that didn't want
to see the Latin Kings evolve.
There were many people,
too, whose incomes
depended on the illicit economy.
And even within the
gang, there were so
many people who didn't want
to lose the stealthy nature
of the game.
They didn't want to come
out and be more publicly
visible as a force for good in
the world, because they were
deeply threatened by a lot of
the traditional power systems
and by having a public brand.
You know, this was a
brand that had always
stayed in the shadows.
So he's someone that I've
continued to talk to and really
focus on how we can build better
risk taking and decision making
skills for youth.
But he also completely changed
my mindset about gang cultures
in the US.
And he's now working
on a memoir project
to help document
some of his stories
from within the Latin Kings.
Another person,
in a similar vein
of how do we use people
that were formerly
within these black market
or illicit economies
and plug them into
the formal economt--
Chris and I were
chatting a little bit
about moonshine,
which I've developed
a new-found appreciation
for, and we've
been taking moonshine around to
a bunch of our launch events.
How many of you guys have
tried moonshine before?
Yeah?
OK.
Are you from, like,
Appalachia, or you just-- it's
like a new hipster phenomenon?
AUDIENCE: Ah, no, no.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
ALEXA CLAY: OK, cool.
They make their own?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
ALEXA CLAY: OK.
Nice.
Yeah, so it's fantastic.
We made moonshine cocktails
at one of our launches,
and it was just-- It's
really a forceful drink.
But to me it's interesting,
because in Tennessee now
it's legalized.
So after the financial
crisis there,
the state decided to legalize
the production of moonshine,
and so now there are
all these companies
that are emerging that
are actually working
with old school bootleggers.
So people that have been
doing this, and it's
been passed on as a
sort of artisanal craft
for generations.
And so the founder of
Sugarlands, for example,
is working with all
these old bootleggers,
and he told me at
their first meeting
he met with a guy
who was drinking
moonshine out of a bear claw.
And so you just have this
really interesting bridge
between these informal
cultures on the one hand
and these new companies
that are trying
to package this and provide
economic opportunity for people
that have been formerly
in the illicit economy.
And camel milk.
Camel milk is another thing
that I have been evangelizing
and forcing people to try.
We profile camel milk
in the book a bit,
looking at the ways in
which Amish camel milk
farmers around the US are
distributing camel milk.
It's now a product that's
available in Whole Foods
here in California, for example.
And it's essentially being sold,
to get around FDA regulations,
through buyer's clubs,
buyer's clubs that
are similar to
the ones that were
created in the '80s to
sell HIV-AIDS medication.
So it's mostly for sold
through membership associations
like that, and there are a huge
group of lobbyists or activists
now who are working
on trying to legalize
camel milk within the US.
Copycats.
Traveling to India and China
and Brazil for this research,
I met a lot of people that
really didn't care a whole lot
about intellectual property.
They basically were fine to
infringe on corporate patents.
And so, for example,
in India I spoke
to someone who was essentially
reverse engineering
pharmaceutical drugs
and making them
much more accessible and
affordable for the poor there.
And this became a really
interesting strategy,
and the more that I
researched this, the more
that I came to see
the ways in which
Western pharmaceutical
companies, in response
to the pressure of
copycat imitators in a lot
of these markets, actually
had to develop tiered pricing
models to compete.
So in this way, the copycats
who were questioning
the monopolistic practices
of a lot of these companies
forced these Western companies,
ultimately, to evolve.
And I think it's a bit ironic,
because certainly in the US,
a lot of the founding of
the US industrial economy
was built on patent robbers
who stole patents from Western
Europe and commercialized
them here in the US,
completely infringing on it.
And yet, it's now companies,
mostly US companies,
who are abroad who
are trying to protect
their IP in a similar way.
And going to another
historic culture,
part of the premise
of this book was
to say, well, what can we
learn from these alternative
economies to actually reprogram
the mainstream economy?
And so we did a lot of
research into self-governance,
into different
ways of organizing.
And it became really
interesting, in fact,
to study historic
pirate cultures,
and to see ways in which
pirates organized their vessels.
And a lot of historic
pirates were actually
escaping the dehumanizing
conditions of merchant vessels,
and so they created egalitarian
societies aboard their ships.
They actually
created constitutions
to govern their vessels before
constitutions were created
by Western European
nations, and they
had more egalitarian pay systems
than the merchant vessels.
And similarly, Anonymous
was another organization--
and a lot of hacker
collectives, actually,
that we studied were
really interesting
in pioneering decentralized
forms of leaderlessness.
You also saw this in
the Occupy movement.
So we really came
to understand ways
in which cultures and
corporate cultures
could actually leverage
principles from decentralized
governance and leaderlessness.
You know, there's not any
one person within Anonymous
that is the spokesperson or that
is controlling the actions that
are undertaken by the group.
Anyone can submit to take
an action under Anonymous,
and then other people that
want to go in on that action
are welcome.
And so that became
another way of thinking
about inspiring
examples of cultures
that were more
self-governing, and now you
do see corporate cultures
that are beginning
to experiment more with this.
And then another element
that we really looked at
was this idea of the hacker
ethos, not merely Anonymous
and IT hackers, but the
ways in which the hacker
ethos was spilling over
into mainstream culture.
And one of my conversations that
just left me totally buzzing
was with this guy Gary Slutkin,
who basically went around
to try and hack the
problem of violence.
So he in a lot of ways was
more of a late blooming
misfit, a reluctant
hacker, but he started off
as a researcher in
infectious disease.
He did work on tuberculosis, and
malaria and HIV-AIDS in Africa
for years.
He burnt out.
He ended up going back
to his native Chicago,
and there in Chicago, started
reading the newspaper,
and reading all of these
incidents of violence
and urban and inner city gangs
and all the issues there,
and so started studying these
patterns of violent outbreak
and recognizing that
violence spreads
exactly the same way that an
infectious disease spreads.
And so from this
insight, he went
about trying to cure the world
of violence in the same way
that you would go about
curing or containing
an infectious disease.
So he created a network of
violence interrupters, people
that could be called
in to mediate instances
where violence might
erupt or might occur.
And in many neighborhoods,
where you don't necessarily
feel comfortable calling
in your local police force,
calling in this trusted
intermediary who
isn't going to
put the law on you
was safer for a lot
of these communities.
And a lot of the
violence interrupters,
similar to the community
health outreach model,
are actually from
these communities,
so they have much more trust.
From there, I've been
doing a lot of research
on another kind of
alternative community, which
are the world of LARPing.
I don't know how many people
have ever LARPed before?
One?
You're Google.
Two.
You've done everything.
You drink moonshine and LARP.
So I'm doing my first
LARP in a few weeks.
But I think this
genre is especially
interesting for testing
out alternative scenarios,
and particularly the
Nordic LARP scene really
allows you to prototype
alternative worlds.
So if you have a
question about--
If you're building an
alternative financial system,
or you're really interested
in living in a communitarian
society, rather than
fully commit to that,
you can actually just spend
three hours exploring what
that world would look like.
And in many ways, I think LARP
is an interesting phenomenon,
too, because you have to inhabit
these alternative identities,
and so that touches a bit
on my love for alter egos
and seeing that as
you begin to inhabit
these different
personalities there's
this phenomenon
of bleeding, where
some of the characteristics
of the character that you're
playing come to bleed into
your normal personality.
And in many ways, sometimes
that can be destabilizing.
Other times it can be
deeply therapeutic,
as you come to test out
different personality traits.
I was interviewing
someone the other day
who told me he learned how to
be an extrovert through LARP.
And so going through all
these different case studies,
we essentially synthesized five
key principles that were really
part of these misfit
economies that we think
can be applied to more formal
systems that are in need
of change and provocation.
And so certainly this idea of
hustle is really important.
It's something that we
see tying the black market
communities of drug
dealers, of gangsters,
with the startup and
tech communities.
The next is really looking
at that hacker ethos,
and how that is not just
functioning within those IT
communities, but spilling over
and becoming-- people, even
intrapreneurs who are trying
to hack corporate cultures
from the inside, or people
that are trying to hack
vital societal problems.
Looking at the power
of copycat behavior
and what happens
when people actually
start collaborating
and putting less
of a premium on
intellectual property.
Looking at-- with LARP, or with
some of the more provocative
artistic protagonists that we
profiled in the book-- looking
at the power of provocation.
Definitely, you see this a
lot in activist groups, too.
But how do we ask the
questions that not only get us
to think about different
business models,
but get us to really
question entire systems?
So we did a lot of
interviews, for example,
with protagonists within
the unschooling system,
and looking at
people that were even
questioning the entire
construct of how
we do traditional education.
And then lastly, you
have maybe heard a lot
about pivots and lean startups.
And so for us we
really looked at pivots
as a different phenomenon,
pivots as personal pivots.
So many of the misfits
that we spoke to
were incredible in
the sense that they
were able to walk
the road less chosen.
They were able to take
these dramatic leaps
and go into new fields and
tolerate a great degree
of ambiguity and take risks.
And so we focus a
lot on these stories
of people that truly got
out of their comfort zones
and were able to bring
diverse worlds together
to accomplish some of their
entrepreneurial ventures.
And as a result, we have
"The Misfit Economy",
the book in front of you.
We also did a spin
out show on NAT GEO,
called "Underworld, Inc."
which ran for a time.
We had a Kickstarter
campaign initially,
where we raised over $70,000.
That got us started.
And we worked with
both traditional media,
but then we've also done
a few quirky things.
So we worked to get
Nigerian spam sent out
around the time of
our book launch,
where we developed
these fake spam notes--
I don't know if you could
see these from here--
and sent these to
all of our friends,
and that was enormously
fun, and a lot of people
didn't realize that it was fake.
And then we also tagged a city.
So we did a bunch of graffiti
around New York City,
and we also tagged
it with stickers.
And then we had a
launch party where
we brought a bunch
of drug kingpins
and sort of big mavericks
within the black market economy
together.
So in the middle
there is George Young,
who inspired Johnny Depp's
performance in the movie
"Blow".
We also have Antonio
Fernandez, who
I mentioned earlier, who was
the leader of the Latin Kings,
and David Victorson, who
smuggled 37 tons of marijuana
from Colombia to
Seattle, Washington.
And this was an interesting
event, because on the one hand,
we brought together
all these leaders who
are amazing entrepreneurs
in the black market economy,
and then we brought
them in conversation
with the tech scene and startup
founders in New York City.
And this is basically what
we want to do more of.
How can we actually harvest
some of these skills
and give these guys more
of a platform, an avenue
to talk about some of the
lessons that they learned
and get this into the
hands of entrepreneurs
who are maybe on the
other side of the law
in the formal economy?
And I think part
of this question
is a question of access.
I recently just
did this bus trip
where I was traveling
around the US,
and in every community
that I went to,
you have amazing spaces like
this, these tech incubator
spaces that have tons
of resources and rock
climbing walls and great foods--
I saw that you were eating
a coconut, which is awesome.
And then on the
other side of town,
you have people
who are basically
just street hustlers, who don't
have any of these resources
but who have all the
skills of entrepreneurship.
And how do we bridge
these worlds together?
So that's part of my
mission moving forward
is that the book isn't
just a book in itself,
but it's an
invitation for people
from these different
communities to find
ways of plugging in and creating
bridges across one another.
And then another
thing that's evolved
is some really interventionist
artistic projects,
where I've been inspired
by some of the misfits
that I've interviewed,
and I've tried
to activate this in my own work.
So I used to write
a lot of poetry,
and no one really
read this poetry.
My parents didn't even read it.
So I maybe had,
like, five people
that would read this poetry.
And so there's so
many poets out there
where this is also an issue.
You have this amazing
language, and yet there's
no real mainstream
audience for it.
So we developed this fun
thing called Porn and Poetry,
where we basically worked
with hackers to hack porn
sites with poems, so as you're
watching a particular video,
you'll suddenly get
this crazy popup that's
not like your usual
porn popup, that's
a beautiful poem
by one of the poets
that we've curated it from.
So that project is going
strong, and has been really fun.
And that brings
me to alter egos.
Another artistic project
that I've been exploring
is a character called
the Amish futurist.
And there's a lot
of good heritage.
We were making fun of
Bowie a little bit earlier,
but there's a lot of good
folks that have experimented
with alter egos themselves.
And my version of this
was this Amish lady.
So I started wearing
Amish clothes and a bonnet
and going around to tech
conferences and startup places
and basically just asking people
very Socratic and existential
questions, trying to get into
the bigger meaning of what
they were doing.
So for me, one of my
prime frustrations
is not really understanding
the bigger role
that the technologies
that people are creating
have on our subjective lives.
Like, how is the
technology that you're
making changing my experience
of intimacy or well-being
in the world?
And so these were some
of the conversations
that I was able to
have as Rebecca, which
is what I call her,
because she's very sweet
and she asks things in
a very vulnerable way
and from an ignorant
place, obviously,
because she hasn't experienced
a lot of technology.
And so that's been
a really fun way
of really provoking that scene
and asking hard questions.
And it also in part comes from
a real love of Amish people.
I've spent time
in Amish country.
I have an Amish newspaper
here with me, actually,
if anyone wants to see.
It's very funny, because
they advertise for phones,
but they advertise for plain
phones in the newspaper.
So it's like as
simple as possible,
where you can't get apps
and you can't text message
and you can only have
credit phone systems.
And in many of these
Amish communities--
Kevin Kelly has written about
this extensively-- you really
have slow adoption
of technology.
So it's not complete
tech abstinence,
but you're really looking
at ways in which you
have these beta testers.
So people with an
Amish community
will test a
particular technology
before it's rolled out for
the entire community to use,
and that's to make sure that
the community understands
the effect of that technology.
And so I've gone around and
talked to in my Amish persona
about the power of buttermilk.
And part of the
power of buttermilk
is the power of tradition,
in that we don't always
need to be innovating,
but that somethings
are really good,
like buttermilk,
and they should stay the same.
And also really
combating this idea
of the Lone Ranger
type of entrepreneur
in favor of more collaborative
entrepreneurship, which
you see more in
Luddite communities
and Amish communities.
And for me personally,
the alter ego
gave me the ability to really
deconstruct my own personality.
It was like LARP in some ways.
It was very therapeutic.
Suddenly I could be in a very
vulnerable, more feminine
and very sensitive
element, and suddenly
get access to a
version of myself
that I didn't have before.
So I think with
alter egos, we all
can actually tap into
this greater elasticity
that we have.
There's so many
different personalities
that we have inside
of us, and maybe we've
come to live out one version
or one kind of script
of who we are that really
plays to our strengths.
But I think part of
the joy of living
is to get to experience as many
different versions of yourself
as possible.
At least that's where I get
a lot of pleasure from it.
And from this, I want to
share a little bit more,
lastly, just about this
interest of prophecy.
Certainly there are
a lot of misfits
who take part in various
prophetic traditions.
I used to study 17th
century astrologers who
were being kicked out of
the scientific establishment
and were always predicting
that the end of the world
was going to come.
And then I also am very
active in following
the hashtag #prepper,
where you just
see all these amazing
different people who
think that the world
is going to end,
and there's a huge market
for prepper goods in case
this is going to happen.
One of my favorite
prepper personas
is this woman Survivor Jane,
and she basically works on--
after the apocalypse
happens, she
makes sure that people
have access to makeup.
So, like, how do you
forage for cosmetics,
and how you look pretty
after the apocalypse happens?
So there are all these
like weird personalities
within the scene.
And for me this asks
this question of, well,
how is spirituality,
how is apocalypse,
how are our prophetic ideals
and religious beliefs changing
as a result of the digital?
Like, if we take this
wiki kind of concept
or peer to peer concept
and apply it to religion,
what does this look like?
How does greater
decentralization and access
to information affect
our spiritual beliefs?
So one of the things
that I started looking at
was this idea of the mash-up,
where increasingly people
are taking a little
bit of Buddhism
or a little bit from
the Torah and they're
mashing it up into their
own spiritual system.
And increasingly it's
becoming individual,
but there's an ability to access
this information like never
before.
And the result of
this was a group
I put together called
Wisdom Hackers, where
we each explored one burning
question that we were holding.
So one person looked at, for
example, festival spirit.
He spent a whole summer going
to various music festivals
across Europe and asking
how do we keep festival
spirit alive in everyday life.
My Wisdom Hacker
question was really
around the nature
of identity, which
was partially my
preoccupation with alter egos.
And this became a community
for us to hold these questions,
where in the busyness
of modern life,
I think we don't often get
to explore deep things that
were actually holding.
And so how do we give
ourselves not just permission,
but also build
accountability with peers
to do some of that
investigation?
So that was something
that we ran.
We had 15 people initially
who each explored a question,
and then we've held global
salons around the world.
And this group next is
putting on something
that we're calling the
Incubator for the Next Messiah,
and this is basically
"American Idol" for gurus.
The whole idea is
how do we apply
the logic of startup incubation
to the guru industry?
So we're going to work with
a major VC backer in San
Francisco-- and I'm
going there next week
to begin scouting people-- and
basically have them kick this
off by launching this
fake press release
where we get them to
talk about their boredom
in investing merely in startups
and say how they want to really
invest in the next guru.
And then we have a whole
source and selection
process for doing that, and
we'll get 15 aspiring gurus
to go through this process.
And this is
interesting, because it
plays to different
markets in different ways.
It can be more of a pure
play reality program,
but then we also hope to embed
more of a satirical group
within it to actually film more
of the funny bits that happen,
and not for it to
be so straight,
but for it to actually be
a bit more of a satire.
And so that plays to
a mainstream audience,
but then also to more
of a snarky audience
that we can cultivate
online and do more guerrilla
and transmedia engagement with.
Great.
So that's all I wanted to share.
Thank you guys so
much for listening.
And I think we have a little
bit of time for a Q&A. Cool.
Great.
So, any questions?
Any alter ego ideas that
people are thinking about?
CHRIS: So I'll
pop up here first.
First let's give a round
of applause to Alexa.
Thanks so much for that.
[APPLAUSE]
And this is something
that we were
kind of to discussing as we
were walking around the office,
but I think it's interesting.
How do you go about sourcing
these people and meeting them
and then securing
interviews with them?
I mean, you're talking
to gang members
and pirates and hackers,
people who generally
don't want to be found.
Can you just talk
about that a little?
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
Yeah.
Definitely.
So there's no LinkedIn for the
black market economy, which
would have been really easy.
There is a fixer industry,
that I didn't realize
until after writing the book.
So there are people
that can connect you
with leading gangsters
or Somali pirates.
I wasn't a journalist by trade,
so I didn't know that existed.
But we really just
asked everyone we knew.
So we went to
different-- You know,
when I showed up in
India, for example,
we were trying to
find someone who
could sell us drugs
initially, and just
take every avenue that we
could to find these guys.
We got in touch with the
guy from the Latin Kings
through the Occupy
Movement, but it was really
just-- There wasn't like
a rigorous ability to be,
like, this is exactly
who we want to speak to,
and it was more just
who we encountered.
But we found some
amazing, incredible folks,
and I think the
book is really-- You
go from starting with an Amish
camel milk farmer to going
to Somali pirates
and then King Tone,
and you begin to see some
of the similarities that
are animating these very
different types of personality.
So it was definitely hard,
and took, like, three years,
and I'm still getting
introduced to people now who
I'm writing about.
AUDIENCE: During that process of
encountering all these people,
how often did you feel
threatened or scared,
or possibly get
arrested or harassed
by non-misfit economy people?
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
So I never really felt
physically threatened
or frightened.
There was one-- If
you saw the video,
I was on the back
of that motorcycle.
That was the worst experience.
That was a gangster who is
a third generation mafia
guy, associated with Dawood
Ibrahim's gang in India,
which is notorious.
And he was a little bit
fucked up that evening,
and decided to perform
for our filmmaker, who
was, like, yeah, great
shot, get on the bike,
and was just like
doing wheelies.
And so I felt like
I almost died then.
There weren't any moments where
we really felt threatened.
AUDIENCE: So it
seems like a big part
of the concept of
the misfit economy
is to question a lot of the
rules that are put forth.
And one of things
you did is you had
a lot of people who are,
in essence, criminals, who
are breaking those
rules for reasons that
help them business-wise,
but then you're
connecting them with startups.
But then you also talk about
the more spiritual side
of thinking through
the process of maybe
not necessarily breaking
those rules, but what that is.
So how are you dealing, I
guess, with that balance?
Because it seems
to me that you have
a big moral issue of telling
people-- which you see a lot,
I think, in startups
and in big businesses,
because they will break
rules that they should not
be breaking and vice versa,
other rules that some companies
break that ends up
making them big.
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you kind of balance
that, I guess, in this concept?
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
I think it's
definitely a challenge.
And I think the first thing
that we tried to overcome
was this idea that we
can't just see the world
in good and evil terms.
Particularly, I think,
having more empathy
for the black market innovators,
because a lot of these guys
were born into poverty,
and this activity
provided a way of actually
growing economically.
So maybe I have more
patience and tolerance
for people that are breaking
the rules in that sense,
because they're coming from
environments of constraint
versus a company like Uber,
whose success really owes
to the fact that they are
breaking a lot of rules
and having regulation
lag behind a lot of that.
So that, I guess, I
have less empathy for.
But I think particularly coming
from my experience of working
with intrapreneurs within
the corporate sector,
they were breaking
rules all the time.
And they weren't like
big regulatory rules,
but there are so many
rules and protocols
that we have within
massive organizations,
in the nature of bureaucracies,
that really stifle innovation.
So for that subgroup of people,
rule breaking or breaking
protocol became an important
part of their own survival,
and a way of getting these
very disruptive, often
social and
environmentally driven,
propositions into the company.
So, yeah, I wouldn't say there's
one blanket answer on that.
But it's definitely
a good question.
And I think the whole
spirit of is how do we
bring greater informality
into the economy generally,
because we've seen the ways in
which industrial economies have
essentially expired.
These command and
control systems,
we can't really
afford to live in them
for a variety of reasons.
So how do we actually
become better
at improvising and creating some
of these new types of systems
that we see more on the fringe?
AUDIENCE: In a
lot of your slides
and what you've
been discussing, it
seems like a
gendered issue, where
a lot of the people who
you're talking to were male.
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
that's attributed
to similar situations where it's
just the patriarchy overall?
Do you think it's some kind
of other kind of system
that's involved there?
And how are women involved
in this situation,
this misfit economy?
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
I think it's really
interesting, because we
tried to find a lot of
female protagonists,
but even within--
you know, there
are Latin Queens in
addition to the Latin Kings.
But a lot of the criminals,
particularly the ones who
were able to take the
most risk and also
able to speak to us, because
of the nature of their egos
that weren't really threatened
by us, they ended up being men.
And I think in many ways,
the sort of personality--
When we had our launch
party, for example,
and these drug
kingpins were there,
there was something really
fatalistic in their thinking.
Like, they knew they
would get caught.
They knew this
wouldn't last forever.
And they were basically
chasing, some of them,
women and money
in a lot of ways.
And I do think since
we've encountered
a lot of case studies of
entrepreneurs that are women.
So within Somali piracy,
for example, it's
not that women are
becoming pirates,
but they're actually supplying
a lot of the narcotic
that the pirates are
becoming dependent on.
And so that's less
risk in a lot of ways,
and they can manage that
domestically while being
embedded locally in community.
Even when I stayed
with an Amish family,
there was one particular woman
who was serving us all dinner,
and then didn't even
sit down with us.
And so you saw
ways in which there
was kind of a patriarchal
culture that was forming.
But then after that,
we all went downstairs,
and she just destroyed
everyone at ping-pong.
She just was, like, totally
wicked and serving and spiking.
And for me it was beautiful,
but there was also
this sort of moment of sadness,
because I realized suddenly
she had all this
energy within her
and all this drive and
force and fierceness
that she didn't really have
an outlet in the world for.
So I think it's
a great question,
and it's something I'm
continually exploring.
But I wouldn't say there's
one narrative that I've really
been able to pull out,
where I can just say, oh,
black market's evil, patriarchy.
But yeah, there are a lot
of issues there for sure.
AUDIENCE: So I guess a lot of
the alternative communities
are sort of antagonistic
to each other,
and I'm kind of
interested in what
happens where these
communities, economies, rub up
against each other, in the sense
that the people that you're
talking to are unusual,
maybe in those--
And so you're sort of talking
to the misfits of the misfits,
in a way.
How did their lives play out
after they've decided that they
wanted to take on that role.
Do they end up just going
back to the way they were?
Do they make a choice?
Do they cross over?
That kind of stuff.
ALEXA CLAY: Yeah.
I think it's an
interesting question.
First of all, we didn't
just try and profile
status quo individuals within
the black market economy.
So even within-- King Tone,
who ran the Latin Kings,
we were trying to
find someone who was
trying to change that culture.
And all the misfits
that we profiled
were people that were
born into certain cultures
and were actively trying
to change them from within.
So I think that's something
they definitely all share.
And your other
question was about what
happens after they sort
of embrace this identity.
Well, I think it's hard.
I think-- And this
is the challenge
of-- The end of the book is,
like, what happens when we all
embrace our inner misfits?
And I think the more
authentic you feel you are,
the more pushback
you can often get
from the cultures or
the institutions that
are hosting you.
So it is often a
balance of how there's
a trade off between
individuality and authenticity
on the one hand and the
degree of conformity
that we need to fit into
different institutions.
Tone failed, ultimately,
at transforming the Kings,
because of the external pushback
and the internal pushback.
And a lot of the intrapreneurs
that we profiled ultimately
had to jump ship, because they
realized these cultures weren't
actually fostering the
type of environment they
needed to bring these
innovations to life.
So I think it's a
really hard balance
for those that can
to try and leave
the cultures they're from.
That's sometimes
the avenue for that.
But in other cases, you just
need enormous resilience,
because you are going
against the dominant culture
and grain of the systems
that you're part of,
and that's exhausting.
And I think both
of my parents did
that in very different
ways growing up,
so it's a sort of
battle that I'm used to,
and it's why have
appreciation for it.
But if you're doing things
that aren't normalized
in the world, where people don't
really understand where you're
coming from, or you're
asking questions
that feel like they're very
alien to people, that can
be very threatening for people.
And so one of the
things we look at
is how these groups
need entourages,
need these support networks.
Whether or not you're
a gangster trying
to transform within
the gang or you're
someone within a
corporation trying
to do that, or even this book
project owes to, like, 20
of my closest friends
who were always there
and able to support me.
So I think for anyone
doing anything that's
a bit offbeat or unusual, having
that core group of support
people that can
normalize your reality
for you is really important
as you're trying to unplug
from the dominant reality.
Cool.
Do I get a present?
CHRIS: All right.
Yeah.
Thanks again so much, Alexa,
for coming and talking.
ALEXA CLAY: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]